[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm constantly kissing
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our brilliant expert guest this week is
the former executive director of the
Adam Smith Institute Sam Bowman welcome
to chicken achi thanks very much for
having me
[Music]
it's great to have you on and thank you
for coming in let's let's just get right
into it we always ask our guests first
of all what's been your journey to to
the place that you're in now how have
you got to where you are district line
or well I call myself a neoliberal I
spent a lot of my twenties I guess
calling myself a libertarian from the
age of about twelve when I read on
Liberty by John Stuart Mill I kind of
thought yeah this is the one for me I am
a liberal of some kind can I just
interrupt you at twelve well I was
interested in that kind of thing from
quite a young age Wow okay
I mean I probably didn't understand but
we don't still don't understand that no
but yes so for most of my kind of
teenage years and twenties I thought of
myself as being a liberal or a
libertarian and so in the last few years
for various reasons I started to kind of
realize or identify in my view that sort
of split going on in the libertarian
world and also kind of a parallel that
kind of split within libertarianism a
distinct group of people who were quite
libertarian in some areas but much less
so in other areas some may be for the
those people who are not fully familiar
with the whole thing can you just lay
out what is libertarianism
so libertarianism is I guess the idea
that individual liberty trumps pretty
much everything else so it's much more
important that the state does not
interfere and and other people don't
interfere with your right to do it you
want with your life to do it you want
with your money with your property than
all the other concerns that we have
so for example a libertarian and a
socialist might disagree about property
rights socialists might say it's
reasonable for us to take money or
property from rich people in order to
give it to poor people or in order to
provide things like health services or
education services to poor people
libertarians to varying degrees would
disagree some libertarians would just
say no it's never acceptable to take
property from one person to give it to
another taxation is theft
taxation is theft other libertarians
would say even though it might seem like
a good idea that will lead to bad
outcomes and then they'll get kind of
some sort of you'll get a spectrum in
between as well
now I can have always they're also very
very strong free free speech people
there people think that you should be
able to have sex with whoever you want
as long as they consent as well and
they're adults you should be able to put
into your body whatever kind of drug you
want you should be able to more or less
move around the planet wherever you want
provided there is somebody in another
country willing to take you there you
know put you up in their house or
something like that and the view the
kind of basic libertarian view is that
kind of individual liberty is the kind
of trumps everything else and and we're
that different differentiates from kind
of conventional liberalism which also
agrees with individual liberty is
important liberals are a much much
broader set of people and they tend to
think that many liberals tend to think
that that kind of individual autonomy
doesn't extend into your economic lives
libertarians think that it very much
does extend to your economic lives and
your economic Liberty is just as
important as any other kind of Liberty
that there is so for a long time I saw
myself as sort of working within that
that vein and I had a lot of time for
libertarians even though I no longer
consider myself to be one I was they as
you said I ran a think tank called the
Adam Smith Institute which for a long
time was the only kind of
self-identified libertarian think-tank
in the UK but for me
libertarianism was always a big tent but
I think began to and I think it has
really split in kind of not very nice
ways into groups that I wouldn't really
identify as being liberals they might
they might be libertarians you know in
the sense that they used that word but I
don't consider themselves to be people
who are that end
student individual liberty and also i
think that and i have become persuaded
and i did become persuaded that
libertarianism was really not sufficient
when it came to the kind of distribution
of resources my view kind of in a
sentence is a neoliberal which is what i
consider myself to be now somebody who
thinks that markets are very good at
creating wealth but they're not very
good at allocating wealth and that
markets really are very brutal
they're very amoral forces and even
though they're very efficient people who
haven't been born with great gifts
people who have been unlucky in their
life will often get a very very bad kind
of sort of slice of the pie a very small
slice of the pie at the end so a
libertarian would say that's meritocracy
they would say that's that yeah they'd
say that's meritocracy that's tolerable
they'd say as long as that you know as
long as the market process has been fair
then the outcomes okay that's that's a
shame that's a pity that that's happened
that there are poor people basically but
the thing I think sometimes with those
tops with libertarians they go well
that's first acceptable and I'm always
thinking it you're saying that cuz it's
not you mate yeah right you might be
that might be true that might be true I
mean that could be true that could be
said almost any political position right
there that there will always be losers
in any political arrangement and it's
and and arrangements that are brutal or
Arrangements that kind of don't do very
much to help those losers it's it's easy
to just say well what if you were what
if that was you and that that's what
there's a philosopher who I don't
actually like that much a lot of people
who consider who have similar beliefs to
me do a guy called John Rawls and one
device he used I'm not a huge fan of his
but one device he uses is called the
veil of ignorance and so if we were
thinking about or what a good sort of
arrangement for society would be imagine
you didn't know who you were in that
society and and then you know only if
you would accept a society where you
didn't know where and that distribution
you would be it would that be a just or
or could that be a kind of a society
that would be sort of morally acceptable
and I think that's a reasonable tool to
use where I disagree with Rawls is that
he thinks that that implies a high
degree degree of equality and for me
equality is not really the end the thing
that we should be carrying about what we
should care about is the well-being of
I'd be much happier to be to live in an
unequal but rich country
I'd rather rather live in somewhere like
the UK which is very unequal than in a
much poorer country that had a much more
equal distribution of wealth and that's
where I think the kind of rauzein
approach isn't always that useful so
what's your solution to this meritocracy
is is brutal problem for me the the kind
of neoliberal arrangement is very low
regulation markets markets are regulated
really only in order to make them work
better so you might have regulations
against cartels or in some cases
monopolies but you don't have
regulations that are there to for
example give workers a bigger share of
the pie but after you've generated the
wealth the point of that being to have
as much wealth generation and to have as
much kind of efficiency and innovation
as possible and then after you've had
the market process through a reasonably
simple tax system and a reasonably
simple wealth welfare system you just
tax the rich and you give it to the poor
and they array from being very very free
markets with simple redistribution of
income from the rich to the poor I mean
that in in theory that's great but we
can you see now the problems we're
trying to tax big corporations is that
they find loopholes in loopholes and
loopholes and it's very very difficult
to tag some effectively like we've seen
with Amazon or with Starbucks I mean how
would you ensure that works well I
wouldn't tax corporations at all
corporations are not the way tax on
corporations is really bad way of taxing
the rich because that money comes out of
investment because thanks Britain
returns to investment lower and it comes
out of workers wages the evidence is
reasonably strong about this where we
should be taxing rich people isn't when
they save or invest their money
investment I think is really good we
should be investment is you not using
resources that you have a claim to so
that other people can and use those
resources in a more productive way so we
should want as much investment as
possible what we should do
what we should be taxing is consumption
so it's when you when you draw down
those investments and say okay I'm going
to buy a boat or I'm going to spend this
money on a night out or
I'm gonna just eat this eat these
resources by spending it on food that's
when that wealth is destroyed that's
when the wealth is no longer usable by
other people and where the work kind of
socially as far as society is concerned
the wealth is no longer useful and
that's the point where we should be
taxing now so we can do that through
there are there may be boring to go into
different types of tax like that
actually the value-added tax is a pretty
good way of doing that I was gonna say
you want 80% vatt on boats that way yeah
I I probably wouldn't have different
rates for different things what I would
probably do is have a flat rate on
everything and then give give poorer
people a cash just a cash payment
because having exemptions so for example
having exemptions on food even though
obviously the point is that poor people
spend a higher fraction of their income
on food than rich people do rich people
spend more money overall on food than
poor people do so the money that we've
not taken in in tax
we're actually effectively giving rich
people more you know we're forgoing more
attacks from rich than we are from the
poor so a better thing to do would be to
have a kind of a flat dat there are
other things as well there's something
called progressive consumption tax but a
tax on consumption
and also a cash transfer to poorer
people to or in fact to everybody we
could just give everybody a cash that's
what I was gonna go next is universal
basic income yeah what do you think
about the idea of yeah you're making it
like Sally's gonna be walking around
just can be you can see yeah I'm a
simple man if I deal in simple like this
how much you're gonna try to work this
out for the UK and I can't I can't work
it out because it depends on what what
you get rid of right so on you could
have a I've never seen Francis so in
before so for example by getting rid of
the exemptions on v80 in the UK we'd
raise about sixty billion pounds extra a
year so you could if you used all that
that would be like an extra thousand
pounds per person a year but that's just
for the vit exemptions now if we said
that the welfare system so things like
housing benefits unemployment insurance
job seekers allowance and things like
that if we said that we wanted to
replace those things with just a basic
cash payment
then the money will be higher but you
have the problem
the problem is that poor people at the
moment get housing benefit and get
Jobseeker's Allowance
and rich people don't get that if you
have a basic income then rich people do
get do you get some fraction of that so
if all you do is eliminate existing
welfare welfare payments to pay for a
basic income then you're effectively
redistributing money that we're spending
on poor towards the rich right that's a
very bad outcome yeah that's not the
kind of outcome that we want yes so
there are different ways of doing it I
this is the reason that I'm kind of even
though I quite like the basic income
idea in theory I think that it's
politically very difficult because what
it would require would be for headline
tax rates to rise in order to kind of
fund quite a high basic income it would
be like saying we're gonna give you
let's say you are a you are a million
pounds a year you work for a plus so
we're gonna give you an extra ten
thousand pounds a year in basic income
but we're also gonna tax you an extra
ten thousand pounds a year in your tax
yeah you'd be that would be neutral for
you that would be how we would kind of
make the system work but honestly I
think it's a pretty hard sell to say
we're gonna raise taxes by this much so
that you know the bottom 25% of society
you get to have this extra amount of
money another way of doing it is through
something called a negative income tax
which is to just say if you are nothing
you will get ten thousand pounds a year
or fifteen thousand pounds a year and
then for every pound you earn after a
single after a certain point will take
away 50 P so you're always better off
you know it's it's kind of fixing the
marginal tax rate so you always have an
incentive to earn more but we're kind of
slowly withdrawing the money as you do
earn more to me I've become I guess less
fixated on kind of grand schemes to
change the welfare system and more
fixated on kind of principles to do with
it's better to if you're a liberal at
least it's better to give people money
than it is to give people services it's
like which would you rather get money a
book voucher or money for Christmas yeah
you know if you're if your grandmother
or your aunt gives you a 20-pound water
stones that cheer I will thanks very
much well what can I do at that a lot of
the money you know Amazon vouchers are
the closest thing to money because you
can spend them all you Amazon has
everything so they're like a bit like
money so there
better than you know body shop 20 pounds
because I don't buy things in the body
shop they don't have anything I want the
same is true when it comes to gun of
government services versus giving people
cash if you'd rather a hundred pounds
worth of NHS vouchers or a hundred
pounds worth of education vouchers to a
hundred pounds you're an idiot because a
hundred pounds can buy everything that a
hundred pounds worth of NHS vouchers or
a hundred pounds worth of education
vouchers can get you but it can also buy
you a lot of other things and and we
might talk about this a little bit later
I have become convinced that the core
liberal belief the thing that whether
you're a left-wing liberal or a
right-wing liberal the the core on when
it comes to markets the core liberal
belief is anti paternalism it's the idea
that people in charge don't know better
than individuals about what's best for
those individuals provided they provided
there isn't some sort of information
that they're not aware of and in that
case we should if we do think that
individuals are the best people to make
the decisions for themselves with that
money we should be looking for a
government that as much as possible and
it's not always possible at least some
courts and things like that it's not
always possible but as much as possible
gives people the cash give people money
according to what they need but doesn't
try and spend it for them and I mean
that's having trust and faith in human
beings isn't it that's where you lost me
I don't have the faith in anybody well
it's not actually a question of having
trusted faith in human beings it's which
human beings do you have trust in faith
in I have no trust in faith in
government human beings I have a little
bit more trust in faith that you have
your own self interests at heart
oh yeah it's a lot so it's not a
question of oh well you'll spend it in a
way that's really good for everybody
else it's just you aren't a better
person to judge what you can spend that
money on then you are so it's purely
that you I think you have the knowledge
and you have the kind of incentives to
spend that money wisely better than
other people do so if actually you know
I would say it's almost distrust of
other people it's kind of cynicism that
makes me prefer a sort of let the
individual decide approach to government
spending so I'm in favor of quite a high
degree of government spending and
government redistribution I just don't
want the government to actually be
spending the money I want government to
take money from the rich give it to the
poor in cash
and then that market to provide the
services that they want with that it
actually makes a lot of sense to me so
we've got a kind of philosophical
background to some of the views let's
talk a little bit more specifics I heard
you talking about Jeremy Corbyn and
we're not huge fans of Jeremy Corbyn on
the show don't let that prejudge your
the attitude but you called you talked
about him being a Marxist and I don't
know if he thought there was a woman on
the good morning show by the time this
goes out it will be a couple of weeks
ago who supposedly shut down Piers
Morgan by ending her whatever she was
saying with I am literally a communist
you idiot I don't know if you caught
yeah yeah sure yeah what do you make of
the rise of this kind of far-left
socialism comments because I'm from
Russia right so for me when someone says
I'm a communist and no one seems to be
amazed by this that's basically like
someone saying I'm a Nazi right given
what communists did in my country in
China in Venezuela all over the place
someone's basically saying on national
television I'm a Nazi you idiot and I'm
they getting praised for it what do you
make of the rise because some of the
ideas you talked about did they sound a
little bit like you know the far-left
just sent in a sense I well I strongly
disagree with the last point yeah I
strongly disagree I think that the kind
of fundamental there's kind of defining
characteristic of the far left is the
idea that the state should organize be
blessed if a state should organize this
it's not that you know it's not that
some redistribution is tolerable pretty
much everybody I mean Milton Friedman
and FA Hayek who are kind of libertarian
liberal heroes of mine both believed in
quite a high amount of government
redistribution so I don't agree that all
right that was a nun family in their
only choice I would like to officially
apologize for the other point I think
we're seeing this on both sites I think
the right is becoming is kept becoming
much much closer the kind of mainstream
right is flirt and much more with the
far right and I think the mainstream
left is flirting much more with the far
left when it comes to the left you're
right there's a total double standard
I mean communism in my opinion communism
and Nazism roughly as bad as each other
communism killed more people Nazism deal
it's murder kind of a
on a per capita basis in a more to the
brutal way and a more targeted and a
more targeted way yeah yeah but in terms
of outcomes I certainly would not want
to live under either kind of regime both
both regimes are totalitarianism that's
the point
um the the obsession over kind of left
and right when it comes to Nazism and
communism misses its totalitarianism
that's the problem and you can give it
whatever kind of flavor
or whatever kind of kind of banners you
want ultimately it's when the when the
state controls people's lives to a total
degree that's when you get this sort of
mass murder and evil and so on um why is
why is communism tolerated in the public
sphere well partly it's because
culturally cultures is just in my
opinion much more left-wing just
institutionally um I I think I don't say
that I don't believe in current really
even know what cultural Marxism is I
don't believe in that but I think it's
obvious that most journalists are on the
Left it's it's basically impossible to
be so left-wing in kind of elite in
elite you know circles in academia and
so on that you're kind of considered to
be untouchable whereas it's very easy to
be so right-wing that you're considered
to be untouchable it's it I mean it
there's basically no way you can say
anything that it in terms of how
left-wing it is that isn't just sort of
laughed off it's like well you're very
you're very optimistic
you're very hope yet if you're a
communist you're at worst you're utopian
and that's not that's not entirely true
there are people on the Left who hate
communism as much as they hate fascism
and nazism but clearly the fact that it
is like a fun Twitter
kind of trending moment that this this
woman said to a Piers Morgan where she's
a communist that's really I think says
so something quite bad partly it's
because your average 18 year old because
we have such a strong filter in society
a strong cultural filter against fascism
and Nazism and for obvious reasons we
fought a war that nearly destroyed
civilization to destroy these people and
it's it's a very thing that we did we've
built up sort of cultural antibodies
it's like a virus that would as soon as
it comes into this
everything shuts down we're going to
destroy it we're gonna destroy this
virus and and that's a very good thing
but we haven't developed those
antibodies to come communism for various
reasons because we were allied to the
Soviets during the during the Second
World War
because the elite because elites have
been quite left-wing for a very long
time long since they're kind of
beginning in the 19th century at least
and so they have a sort of well you know
I might no good want to go as far as
them but I definitely sympathize with
their aims and so on and partly because
fascism and Nazism just have much more
evil kind of motivations communists can
at least claim that well I didn't I
don't mean for it to go into death camps
and blue likes and I mean for it to go
so it to go really nicely whereas it's
very hard to say you're a Nazi and not
and and kind of disavow yourself of of
the kind of basically evil intentions
but I think that because we have quite a
lot of tolerance for you know the 18
year old communists or the kind of
mid-twenties sort of cool communist type
person because of that we allow we allow
that kind of mean to grow much much more
in my opinion we shouldn't be saying
look you're evil if you're a communist
but we should say you should be aware
but the thing you're in favor of is as
evil as the thing that these evil masses
are in favor of you know you don't mean
for this to happen but you should be
aware that this is what happens and I
don't think we do that
you know there's very little in in terms
of history I mean history in the UK is
very much focused on when it does come
to kind of the 20th century ideological
struggles it focuses on the kind of ease
what evils of Nazism and fascism and
doesn't really go that much into
communism communism is almost sort of
treated as I said actually quite
interesting you know the British Library
did and it is quite a statically
interesting you know I understand all
these things and I I don't think
anybody's bad for this but any but it's
sort of treated as a curiosity and as a
thing that occasionally went wrong
rather than something
kill me now that's kind of inherently
you know at best like giving a drunk
child the keys to a car filled with
people you know that's that's look at
the best possible way of describing
communism like the most generous
possible ways it's it's something it's
like you're doing something so stupid
you might not realize what you're doing
you bet you're doing something so stupid
that you are criminally negligent the
money would go viral on the Internet
well yes well right exactly you know and
I and Piers Morgan is an [ __ ] but
because either Piers Morgan actually is
the [ __ ] that he appears to be
on-screen or he's such an [ __ ] that
he acts like an [ __ ] that he appears
to be on screen neither I don't know
which is worse I actually I suspect
Piers Morgan being in on the joke is
worse than there's more than not being
in on the joke and so yeah it's fun
watching somebody tell him he's an idiot
on his show that's great but it's I
think people are excessively generous
but for various reasons so it's about
education it's more about challenging
than education I would say you know I I
think it's important to just establish
in terms of their outcomes communism
announced ISM roughly as bad as each
other that is a that is a very I don't
want to get into you know which is worse
and that's useful is that better uniform
so by Hugo Boss yes but they mean
actually what's interesting is how much
of Western much of what we know to be
the aesthetics of evil very much of that
has come from that ISM you know it's and
a lot of the omiai there's a brilliant
book called Hitler and the power of
aesthetics and it's about the self
conscious attempt by the kind of Nazi
regime to sort of develop a sort of
quasi near Roman sort of aesthetic and
that's now what we kind of associate so
this goes back the reason I'm going this
is this goes back to the kind of
cultural antibodies we've got there's
you know we this it's so deep into our
consciousness that Nazism is evil which
clearly is that that even this sort of
their icons that are used in kind of
started Star Trek that the or or in kind
of start
Wars there's in other words you know no
it's not that closely modelled on I
don't fit or anything still uses the
same kind of uniforms and so on it's
just so it was that deeply ingrained
into people's consciousness which which
is which is interesting and you and and
you can kind of understand you know I'm
try it what I guess I'm trying to get
across is I can see why we've come to
this point I have quite a lot of
sympathy the average as I say the
average 18 year old communist I think
it's probably a bit silly I don't think
they're you know they're often not that
stupid even whereas the average 18 year
old Nazi is either probably a
combination of both deeply stupid and
probably deeply quite evil you know so
there there's clearly a difference in
terms of the intentions of people but I
think that rather than educating or as
well as educating I would like to be
challenging those people more and I and
I would like to just establish you might
not realize this but everybody else does
think you guys have just as bad as each
other in terms of what you're actually
promoting one thing that blew my mind is
when Castro died and so I'm in the
comedy industry which is incredibly
left-wing and the amount of people who
went on the internet mourning his death
well I just I just found it unbelievable
and especially because my mother's from
Venezuela - oh did a speech in Venezuela
in 2009 five I think it was where he
talked about the evils of the internet
and how he said all young people
shouldn't go on the internet and he got
openly booed yeah well and it's just a
fact that people would go on the
internet and use a tool that he himself
prevented his own people from using to
mourn his death
yeah that's astonishing yeah but I mean
again they were probably talking to tell
themselves well he was an idealist you
know he wanted it to be this way but it
had to be this way and as if that's an
important distinction you know I really
have very little time I mean I know it
so it's one of the reasons that I'm a
neoliberal is that I think outcomes
matter above all else I don't care what
your intentions are pretty much in any
situation I don't care about your
intentions I care about the outcomes and
what actually happened and what does
this actually look like in real life
and I think that's a when it comes to
people praising Castro because I'm sure
he remember him really well in the
nineteen
[Music]
so coming back to my Jeremy Corbyn
question and I take back what I said
about your ideas sounding left-wing what
I meant was yes I understand the
difference between a planned economy and
what you're talking about which is a
very loosely regulated economy but the
wealth redistribution yeah it's kind of
part of that right yeah do you think
that the rise of someone like well Rises
a relative term but the emergence of
Jeremy Corbyn is a viable leader of the
Labour Party the huge popularity Bernie
Sanders gathered from young people in
America during the last election is that
an indicator of the fact that wealth
redistribution is an issue that's really
really key right now I think partly I
think the underlying cause of of that
and the of the broader and I see Corbin
and Trump and Sanders and lepen and the
Italians that the lega Nord a-and the
five star movement as all being kind of
part of the same that you know some are
on the left of sensibly some are on the
right but the people vote for them as a
sort of the system has failed us no
b-but we were truck what were you
thought was working isn't working and I
don't blame them for that right
productivity growth which is the kind of
bedrock of economic growth getting
better at doing what we're doing is that
is economic growth and that's what leads
to wages growing it's been abysmal in
the UK it's been worse than abysmal in
Italy as far as I as far as I remember
I think Italians are no richer now than
they were in 2002 so they're effectively
stagnant for the last 16 years and it's
been a bit better in America but it
hasn't been
I mean wage growth has still been pretty
poor and they had a much deeper
recession than we did and if you are
somebody who is on the median income
you're in the middle in the UK you're
lucky if you're if your wages in real
terms are what they were ten years ago
it's it's very very possible that they
were are not what they were ten years
ago I mean well of course why wouldn't
you be a korbinite you know I would be a
korbinite if I wasn't
somebody if I didn't have quite strong
beliefs about economics and politics
already yeah of course I'd be a
korbinite it's not just to do with
income growth in the UK
I mean housing is the is the biggest
expenditure for almost everybody and
housing in the places that people
actually want to live is increasingly
expensive and difficult to and and worse
it's not just the price but it's the
quality so you you used to have flats
with a sitting room a kitchen and two
bedrooms that are now a bedroom a
bedroom a bedroom and a kitchen and you
know and that's not picked up exactly by
the by the rents data and obviously
house prices are very very high and it's
quite difficult to afford to buy a house
the reason is that we don't build enough
of them but yeah of course especially if
you're younger why wouldn't you be a
carbon III I would I would I would be
shocked if I met somebody who didn't
have kind of pretty strong beliefs that
we heard of already would that would
kind of almost inoculate them against
Corbin ISM if they weren't all right if
they weren't korbinite so to me the kind
of fundamentals the sort of economic
fundamentals matter quite a lot and are
the sort of explanation for why we have
this sort of dissatisfaction and then it
the proximate reasons they're kind of
specific to each country reasons then
might explain why you get Trump in one
country and why you get Corbin in
another or why you get Bragg's or
something like that so you know they
have quite strong concerns by Hispanic
immigration in the u.s. so people are
more inclined to vote for Trump and
there's pretty good evidence around that
you obviously have the migrant crisis
which leads to support for or ban in
Hungary and leonor day in Italy so in
each country there are kind of specific
things in those countries that kind of
might tell you the flavor of if you want
to call populism national nationalist
populism might be the best term for it
but and Corbyn is a nationalist populist
you know Corbin is very Pro brexit he's
very Pro hard brexit and in in my view
he is just as much a nationalist really
in I mean I he's not in favor of freedom
of movement with you
he's he's a person who is just as much
nationalists as Nigel Farage just in a
different way so if you were talking to
a young korbinite what would you say to
them are the reasons that they shouldn't
be a young korbinite I mean I don't even
know if I would try and argue them away
from being a young core of a knight
I'd say I think you're wrong I think I'd
say I'm strong I'll give you this I'd
say I'd say that I have a lot of
evidence right now that I'm right you
know I would say that my solution I
think I've got I do have evidence that
building more houses is a better way of
getting house prices down than rent
controls and I and I have evidence that
if the private sector builds those
houses they'll be nicer to live in then
if the government or local council
builds those houses there you won't have
people dropped into sink estates and
forgotten about if it's done by the
private sector instead of done by the
government I probably agree that Corbin
is no worse on brexit than the
government is because I think the
evidence is reasonably clear that most
younger people are kind of
disproportionately anti brexit and as am
i and I think I'd say well yeah he's not
he's not much worse than the government
on that a lot of people seem to be
voting him on the assumption that he is
a lot better than the government he's a
lot more kind of pro-eu or kind of
pro-british membership of the EU than
the government is but I but I feel like
the real people that I want to argue
with them that I do argue with of the
government because it's a whole very
well for me to say to the to the Corbin
voter oh you should do what I want to do
but nobody's doing what I would do the
people who should be doing what I want
them to do which is to deregulate the
housing sector so we can build houses
and make it cheaper for Google to buy in
to rent our the government and I think
it's gotten a lot worse I'm not sure
Riza made but the Conservative Party in
particular is completely bankrupt of
ideas I think they have no idea where
they're going they have kind of
intentionally choked off this sort of
source of ideas that the preview in
previous generations was think tanks and
newspaper columnists and so on and and I
think that they're you know they're
they're really they're the ones who
deserve the blame for impact
did the slow global recovery since the
financial crisis is not their fault but
just as the financial crisis wasn't
Gordon Brown's fault but the government
could have done and could easily do a
lot more to increase economic growth
here and that would mean wage growth and
to lower house prices and that would
mean the cost of living falling and
they're not doing any of that so I
wouldn't be arguing with the Corbin
voter I'd be arguing with the Tory voter
and I'd be saying get these people to to
actually do something to make the market
actually work for people instead of just
trying to put out fires across the
country across the economy but isn't the
issue with the house with housing prices
that no government politically can
afford to allow housing prices to fall
because the people who vote the vast
majority of the people who vote and
owned homes don't want that to happen
and so you end up in this I think is
called a wealth trap in economics where
you kind of let house house prices to
fall because the price you would pay for
that politically would be so high you
probably wouldn't be elected again for
generations because the people who'd
lost value in the in the homes would
never vote for your party again that's
possible in 1992 there was a pretty
sharp reduction in house prices and
obviously the subsequent years weren't
very good for the conservative party but
it doesn't seem like they were it wasn't
house prices in particular that it was
more to do with the kind of I guess
people were bored of having you know 17
years of conservative government and so
on and I'm not I'm not completely
convinced that house prices falling
which would put the Tories out of power
and I do think that a kind of grand
policy like abolishing the green belt
would be pretty bad for the toys I think
that we possibly overestimate in
politics how much people vote out of
self-interest and underestimate people's
idea of what and can don't properly
appreciate people's idea of what's kind
of good for society my view is the green
belt yeah some people are voting to
protect with green dough to protect
their own house price I think a lot of
people are protecting an idea of England
and an idea of kind of green lungs for
the cities that people can go to and
that's on one hand that makes it more
challenging as an economist should kind
of design a system that might
satisfy them but on the other hand it
means that if they could be convinced
that we could have a greener system for
example we could say new developments
need to have more parks and gardens
personal gardens tend to be
environmentally a lot better for the
environment than the farmland that's on
the Greenbelt because their bio diverse
and green land farm belt is usually a
monoculture there are things like that
that we could do we could point out that
people go to that garden and go to their
local park much more often than they
then go to the Greenbelt in fact the
statistics for London are that the
average person visits the Greenbelt -
actually for recreation less than once a
year which is pretty bad if the great
Bell is supposed to be there for
recreation or for a kind of immunity and
I think we can do marginal improvements
so we can make it easier to densify
streets we can allow the streets by
streets to have just votes just I live
on a street in South London
there's no real reason that I shouldn't
be able to perhaps in association of
some lucky property developer set up a
little vote for my streets everybody is
allowed to add one story to their
building and there you go that's 50
extra flats
you know maybe 60 extra flats on that
street there's no reason that that
shouldn't be possible or the individual
housing house owner is their benefit
they get to improve their property and
there you've sort of improved the
connection between new house building
and the existing homeowner is benefiting
there are things that we can do to just
allow more density in general without
necessarily having a lot more towers
although I would like quite a lot more
towers but I think being fatalistic
about it is the is the thing that we
have to avoid because really if you do
if you if you don't build more houses
out of fear of how of homeowners
punishing you you're gonna you're gonna
have known homeowners punishing you you
know somebody's going to punish you and
at least by building more houses you
create more growth you create more
wealth there's more stuff there people
are better off generally in politics I
think the best thing to do is to think
one step ahead not two or three and
because it's the world is so complex
that even if you just get that one step
ahead right you're
pretty lucky and do you think it's a
problem especially in London where
people buy flats not in order to live no
in order to stay not even in order to
have a holiday or whatever it may be
it's simply as an investment or do you
think there's a problem that's been over
exaggerated by the media it's been
massively exaggerated especially foreign
buyers and foreign owners are more
likely I believe to let the unit's be
empty which obviously if you're buying
it to rent it out that shifts the market
somewhat towards rental that isn't
obviously a bad thing
lots of people rent and I have just
written just this weekend I made a
decision I was considering buying a
house and I decided I'm gonna rent for
at least another year because it gives
me flexibility and freedom so renting
renting isn't that foreign ownership
just in general of luxury flats and in
London is a very very small fraction of
the market in terms of actual units it's
quite a big fraction of the market in
terms of the money because the flats are
so expensive but in terms of the the
actual the actual number of units it's a
drop in the ocean so I don't think it's
I don't think it's that important I
think it's more I think any issue like
that
so we also the problem of them or the
the possible probably excuse me the
possible problem of land banking where
developers have permission to build on a
plot but don't build on it for five or
six years and there are actually
rational reasons for that it's because
they need to be able to queue up for a
given amount of kind of workforce and
capital and so on they need to have kind
of an assurance that for the next six
years our plots they'll be able to build
on but it's also pretty annoying if
you're a local council you give
permission to build to build on a piece
of land and they don't go for that you
think well what's the point you know why
are we bothering to go to this political
effort but all those things are symptoms
of a deeper problem housing shouldn't be
an investment that the fundamental
problem is that housing is an investment
it shouldn't be an investment any more
than you know a plane ticket is an
investment or a or a car you know
a used Toyota is an investment those
things are consumption goods there
things that we pay for because we like
using them housing should be the same
their only reason that housing is an
investment good the only reason the
housing is more economically like a
piece of fine art or a piece of gold is
because then the supply is fixed or the
supply is nearly fixed and that's
because of the planning system so then
so the problems that people exist which
I admit I in my opinion the foreigners
problem is a small part of the problem
but it's clearly any unit that's going
vacant is is sort of suboptimal you know
is it's not what we want if there are
people who don't have places to live but
the problem is that it's an investment
good and it shouldn't be an investment
good but the other problem there Sam is
that housing is the only time in the
normal person's life when they can
borrow a huge amount of money to gamble
with right you cannot borrow 200
thousand or 300 or 500 thousand pounds
from a bank yeah to invest in the stock
market yeah as an ordinary person but
housing is one area where you can't do
that because you've got the collateral
of the house and I think that's what's
happened over the last 20 years is a lot
of people have treated it as an
investment as you say not because they
have money sitting around you know best
in it but because they've been able to
borrow money to do that and the second
homes issue I think is one of the
reasons that also the government doesn't
want allow house prices to fall because
if they were a lot of these people would
lose out and again as I say politically
the price would be yeah be very happy I
think that's right i I've you that as
some two blades of a scissors you you
kind of need both for the effect that
we've seen to happen it it doesn't
matter how much you can borrow to fund
the price of a car right borrowing
interest rates fall and doesn't mean the
car prices rise even though people could
in could in theory by borrow more to
buying to get a bigger auto loan because
the supply of cars is pretty elastic as
demand increases we just build more cars
so yeah you can borrow a hundred
thousand but you just end up with five
Toyotas instead of one in this set of
1/12 and they will diminish in value
over time yeah yeah exactly because
because they're not investment goods
because we can just build more of them
as we want to their consumption goods in
most part classic cars are different
because they are actually fixed in
supply but modern cars to get modern
cars are
I'm talking about can I just say this
has been sponsored by giving it you know
given immigrants in Venezuela to do
anything for money yeah curat yeah it's
I mean it is the two blades of a
scissors um I think you're right though
that there is a what economists call a
moral hazard in the same way that when
you bailout a bank you encourage the
bank to take risks to take more rights
in the future and when when the bank
thinks it'll be bailed out you encourage
them to take more risks then there might
be an implicit moral hazard in the
system where people if you're looking at
a mortgage for one thing you know this
I'm sure isn't a system-wide problem but
it is very strange when you look at the
cost of a mortgage that they only show
you the based on today's interest rates
when we know that interest rates are
going to rise in the future now I don't
think the bank would lend that money out
if they didn't think that they've get
that money back but I do think it's
possible that a lot of people are
borrowing money without realizing that a
much bigger fraction of their income is
going to be taken up in interest
payments in five years time once
interest rates are probably up by you
know half a percentage point one
percentage point I don't know
that's me seems like a huge nasty
surprise but a lot of people are facing
yeah I think it's two blades of a
scissors
[Music]
or let's move on a little bit talk about
technology you're someone who's
optimistic about the future technology
our producer before we started this show
was convincing me they were about to
eliminate scarcity and everything is
gonna be dandies he write about that
he's not allowed to join in by say
whatever you want no I don't think we're
gonna eliminate scarcity ever no ever I
mean [ __ ] you're wrong that's it that's
it you're wrong try time time will
always be scarce you know we will always
have a scarcity of time even if resource
has become abundant in super abundant
its time will always be scarce so we'll
always have to figure out ways both of
using our own time and of using other
people's time and a lot of you know a
lot of what we want from other people is
their time whether it's to do a service
for us order to spend time with us I but
I think we're very very far away from
material super abundance and it's true
that the kind of basic some of the
basics of living are very cheap to me
technology is more likely to expand the
frontier of what we can do than it is to
kind of make it trivially easy to and
until we have kind of extremely
extremely good AI that isn't so good
that it can that has a desire to
eliminate us for self-interested really
rational humans until we have that I
mean there's a then we get into other
questions about kind of the dangers of
AI and so on but I think what's more
likely is that technology will make kind
of recreation much more enjoyable and so
I think that might be the thing that you
know Keynes famously wrote an essay
about 100 years ago called the economic
possibilities for our grandchildren and
he sort of famously predicted you know
working three hours three days a week
and so on and his view was that and what
they had at the time in terms of
resources like what your kind of weekly
income was that was enough for anybody
so as we get better at making things
we'll stick with that and then we'll
just spend more time off and as it
turned out actually we just wanted more
stuff and we just we are our desire for
more stuff is just infinite and so we
kept just our frontiers of sort of what
we
it just grew and grew and grew and
that's good that's a fact that's fine
the the only thing that my push against
that is that if actually leisure itself
can become more pleasurable
so Tyler Cowen who's an economist in
America he writes their marginal
revolution blog along with Alex Tabarrok
he argues that to some extent and this
sounds a bit silly but to some extent
youth unemployment is probably partly
driven by video games because it's much
more enjoyable to be unemployed now than
it was to be unemployed 15 or 20 years
ago there's more you can do with your
with with spare time and I mean somebody
who just spent the weekend playing on my
switch my auto path traveller RPG just
came out and it was a great weekend you
know in between World Cup games it was
too hot to go outside so I just play
video games and as that becomes better
and as sort of leisure as we because we
come up with better things to do with
leisure
so it might begin with virtual reality I
think simulated reality when you when
you actually experience the thing in
your head is is the real is the real
price that we really should be looking
for but it's things like that probably
better drugs come available sounds like
a great future we just thought going to
be high playing computer and that's
basically my University that was my
University too and I like that yeah
happily go back there now I'll be honest
with you and so yes I mean there are
there are certain dimensions to do with
in terms of kind of making the world
better I think would be a lot easier to
feed people it'll be a lot easier to
prevent people from dying of disease and
that's obvious but I think the really
interesting dimension will be as leisure
time gets better and better
it's it's inconceivable to me that the
kind of innovative the kind of advances
we're making in biochemistry and in
genetics that we will not figure out how
to for example give a kind of time
limited experience that similar to
taking ecstasy or cocaine in a very safe
way I just think it's inconceivable you
know I like I mean the argument the the
best argument against what I'm saying is
how bad artificial sweetners still are
you know in legal to research artificial
sweeteners for
and they still suck you know they're
still unbelievably bad compared to sugar
but they operate in slightly different
ways and I think that as we move towards
drug legalization and I think we are and
I think we will legalize most if not all
drugs quite soon as really within my
lifetime it's what I mean by within your
lifetime yeah I think cannabis will be
legalized here within five years within
five years yeah when 2018 we'll have you
back on into 23:23 I can't have a joint
on set yeah but actually we can't
because we're smoking indoors it's no
longer like oh yeah that'll be that
little bit very bad yeah yeah you have
to you'll have to smoke it in special
government approved areas but which will
take all the joy out
yeah well that's it so that's the like
the gray education of life you know as
we as we kind of move towards greater
liberalism in terms of drugs as I think
we are the reason I say five years is
because I don't think it'll happen
before the next election but I think it
will happen straight after with every
election yeah hold on what's your
evidence for that because the major
parties both opposed to it
the last time this issue came up in a
massive way I don't think was about 2010
the guy who we were trying to get him on
the show and hopefully we all David Nutt
oh he got basically he got us to be vile
he got us to leave right for saying that
marijuana is not as bad as yes I mean he
could he completely correctly he heard
the dangers the deaths from exiting to a
deaths from horse-riding yeah for making
a correct completely clear anybody could
check the data Harrison he was fired
yeah right so that's my point
yeah politically this issue doesn't I
mean I tell me what you're saying that
I'm not saying it's it's the shift in
the United States there it's moving
there for different reasons one one I
think being that the like the the
paradox being they're much more liberal
drinking culture means that it's much
more normal for kind of just smoking
cannabis is just much more widespread in
the US than it is here even more
widespread in the u.s. than it is here
that has now led to it being legalized
in on the entire west coast now
California the really crucial state
because it's so culturally important
because most TV shows in America most
kind of sitcoms things like that are
filmed in California
these things have been more an enormous
cultural impact and I think they
normalize it in a way that is sort of
the key to getting to me gay marriage
happening the cause of that was cultural
normalization it was having gay
characters and TV shows that weren't
kind of jokes they weren't kind of
people that were there is like haha
let's laugh at these people they were
just normal human beings who happen to
be gay and I think that that helped
people who maybe didn't know people like
that in their lives and maybe didn't see
gay people like that to begin to see
that in that way and I think a similar
thing will probably happen with cannabis
are you saying Will and Grace made gay
marriage yeah almost certainly yeah I
would say that it had a huge huge
contributing effect yeah I mean I don't
have data for this so I tried it you
know I'm straying off my economists
territory but yeah I think normalization
is for kind of a key to that kind of
liberalisation and I think that as it
gets normalized across America we just
follow America I mean the UK just
follows all political discourse follows
American discourse you know we have
arguments about things that have nothing
to do you know that just are not
relevant in the UK we have huge
arguments about like black lives matter
which just isn't a thing in the UK you
know there are problems to do with the
police and so on but the kind of things
that black lives matter were campaigning
about still somehow this became the kind
of number one thing that we were talking
about because we consume so much
American media and we're you know we
just we just take and and this happens
left and right politically we look to
Americans for what we're what for what
we talk about you know um one of the
major that the the woman Nash soccer who
we talked about earlier who was on him
said to I'm literally a communist yeah
yeah she was she was in Teen Vogue kind
of which isn't actually a thing that
teenagers read I don't think I think
it's like a weird especially a problem a
kazoo but sort of it's a weird thing but
anyway and she's sort of saying oh why
am i a communist and it was something to
do with she's against sort of military
imperialism which is a big income you
never did any of that right sure sure
military imperialism putting too many
people in jail
never did anything either and I and the
third one was something to do with I
wish I could remember but either way
they were things that are American
talking once there that we don't we
don't have a mass mass imprisonment in
the UK yeah we don't we don't put
millions of people in jail in the UK the
way they do in America or all of the
things that people think about terrific
oh yeah and sorry the third one was the
separation of children and their parents
when they when they migrated into the US
which I which I think is appalling and
which I hate but these are just
something that we do in the UK and so
you're defining yourself by American by
American talking points by American
political wedge issues and everybody
does you know Liz Trust who I think is
wonderful their chief secretary to the
Treasury
gave a speech about occupational
licensing now in the u.s. occupational
licensing you need to have a license to
become a hair braider you know
everything is licensed it's insane in
the UK you need to have a license to be
a doctor or a lawyer and maybe two or
three other things just everybody just
adopt these American political talking
points and political wedge issues
wholesale because that's where our
that's what our culture comes from so I
think with cannabis it's no different as
America legalizes we will legalize as
well it doesn't the parties don't define
things really they just follow the rest
of it they just follow culture when it
comes to stuff like this
that's fascinating my view so joints all
around yeah you such a square no I know
yeah I really I think it's an awful drug
makes me feel ill and makes me sleepy so
there you go yeah one of them oh so what
do you think about cocaine
I made you joint no no I'm [ __ ] I
mean in terms of do you think that's
gonna be legalized anytime soon or do
you think that's gonna be a much harder
sell I think it's a harder sell probably
cocaine is is harder than MDMA because
cocaine is reasonably easy to turn into
crack and if cocaine became widely
available I actually don't think people
will move on to crack because the reason
you smoked crack is because it's cheaper
per kind of the effect it has than
cocaine is
I mean crack exists really because
cocaine is expensive and legalization
would make it much much cheaper but that
might be an issue but I think MDMA
cocaine and cannabis are the three that
really there should be no debate about
legalizing heroin it becomes much more
difficult because it's so strongly
addictive and it's it's much more like a
kind of medical problem and kind of
paternalism where you know which I said
earlier being anti paternalist is is
sort of defining liberal trait but but
heroin is where most people I think
including myself although I I don't I
don't know for certain would say that
you're kind of not in your right mind if
you if you take heroin you've sort of
become you've kind of lost you know you
don't have your full faculties available
to you but cannabis MDMA and cocaine no
question they'd be much safer for one
they'd be probably a lot more enjoyable
which is important you know it's maybe
enjoy the MDMA in the cocaine around
[Music]
so what's the future according to Sabo
and where we're gonna be five ten years
from now what are we not seeing that's
coming towards us well I think
politically a lot depends on
productivity growth I know it's a
exciting and sexy concept a lot depends
on us getting being able to return to
the kind of trend that we were at before
the crisis it really seems as if
something has broken in the economy that
means that it's sort of fundamentally in
terms of output growing at different in
different ways and that people at the
top the kind of software engineers and
the people who are very gifted will be
able to grow and grow and grow and be
able to be extremely productive and and
innovative and that's good for everybody
because you get to use the products they
make but it's not so great in terms of
the in terms of incomes if this is sort
of coming apart of the kind of cognitive
elite and the kind of everybody else
continues and I don't think that's just
an economic problem I think it's a
social problem I think they're feeling
that somebody else has a great life and
you don't have a great life okay I mean
that's a very troubling theory of
feeling and the feeling that your kids
aren't going to have a great life and
somebody else's kids gonna have a great
life that's a very very troubling thing
and I think that's a may be at the root
of kind of where we are politically
right now
and I don't know if and that's why I
think the kind of economic fundamentals
matters so much because that's what
that's what determines whether you feel
like tomorrow is going to be better than
today was and next year will be better
but for your kids than this than this
years and whether that changes and I
don't know I think it probably will I
tend to think that the economy and the
global economy is more robust than
people give it credit for
I think China
China not stagnating matters a lot if
China continues to grow then that's very
very good for everybody else that's that
that's
not only a country that is just
producing things demanding things buying
things but it's also a country that has
strong stake in the global kind of
trading the global liberal trading order
becomes relatively free trade order
being preserved and in kind of peace in
the sort of Eurasian continent being
preserved so I think that's a good thing
an India might drive that as well but I
don't know I think it feels to me like
Europe and the United States are kind of
stagnating a bit and it feels apart from
the Silicon Valley element of the United
States like Europe is too focused on AI
it's too focused on kind of getting the
rules right and kind of getting a
perfect set of rules when it comes to
technology and when it comes to the
economy and trade and so on and when it
comes to migration naturally when it
comes to kind of refugees coming in
bruno Mackay's who's a former portuguese
Minister for Europe has his book called
the dawn of Eurasia and his so the way
he describes the European Union is and I
say this is a person who's anti brexit
he's as people trying to kind of design
a system that can run without human
control and so they're trying to devise
kind of formula for allocating refugees
to countries and it's just crazy because
that's not what the real world is and
that's not what politics is and I
worried that that sort of obsession was
kind of getting the kind of building
this sort of perfect beautiful structure
the perfect beautiful Constitution will
really hurt Europe because they've
missed the kind of energy and dynamism
that is what really drives economic
improvement and in the u.s. I think all
sorts of you know the the kind of the
Trump the Trump madness seems to have
infected the whole political culture
there and it really the ultimate problem
actually in the US and I think possibly
will come over here because the downside
of us taking all American politics is
that we take all American politics but
is the the bleeding of politics into
every step of people's lives you know is
is
everything becomes a political action
politics really in my view should be a
thing that weirdos debate amongst
themselves and that doesn't really
matter very much to people talking about
it should be like football you know it
should be a hobbyist thing this if you
like it you like it and it's you can
choose a team you know we can have a fun
argument we can some maybe you know we
can argue in maybe changing other's
minds or not whatever and and that and
that's that it's like a kind of a
hobbyist thing it shouldn't be something
that obsesses people at every point in
their lives
and unfortunately whether people like it
or not it is now something that affects
every every element of their lives and
that for me is a kind of a sort of
modest case for a small state or for a
limited state is that politics makes us
hate each other politics makes us
enemies and adversaries because politics
really is zero-sum game most of the
world is not a positive sum game we can
interact with each other and we're both
better off but politics is zero-sum game
if you get this I don't get it and so we
hate each other when it comes to that
and I think that a the more that that
kind of mindset bleeds into more
elements of our lives and the more our
interactions with each other are defined
by what side are you on
the more will hate each other and my
fear is that that will happen in America
and I worry that that might spread to
the rest of the english-speaking world
as well how much you blame social media
for that to some extent a little bit I I
don't know how much I blame social media
I've been certainly I blame all people
using the Internet it's true I mean
young people know that most of the
Internet is bollocks you know young
people they kind of have an inoculation
against what they read online whereas
all people are much more credulous
because they're used to what they read
being true and they're used to having
kind of gatekeepers only you let them
read what's basically true so yeah I
blame and I mean no people are much much
much more susceptible to fake news and
to not just fake news but kind of crappy
news you know you know fake news is I
actually just lies crappy news is
heavily biased you know there might be
there's there's probably some
the words are probably true but what
they're missing means that they've
slanted the story in such a terrible way
all people are really susceptible to
that because they're really they're used
to news being a thing that's very
neutral and that they can trust so I
think it might be a little bit I mean
this is a this is a kind of you know the
expression apart from that mrs. Lincoln
how is the play maybe a bit like this
but to say that this might be a bit like
the printing press which we eventually
got used to it took about a hundred
years of bloody civil war and everybody
hating each other because religion is
what to find their lives so it might be
it might be I hope it doesn't come to
that I'd leave social media to some
extent if I could push a button and just
sort of magically mean that nobody
wanted to talk about politics online I
think that would make the world a lot
better place I wouldn't sense of them
because I don't want to give anybody the
power to censor that but they kind of as
I I'm a huge free speech person because
I think that free speech helps us arrive
at the right answer then free speech and
science is what helps us arrive at the
right answer and if you didn't have free
speech and science then you would often
get the wrong answer and I sort of draw
that into other areas of our lives free
speech in markets is good because it
allows us to say this is a good product
this is a bad product don't go to this
company because they'll rip you off
that's a really great way of making
markets honest but I don't know if
politics has the same kind of correction
mechanisms politics seems to not have
the kind of correction mechanisms of
science and markets for you know if a
theory is wrong you can test it and it's
wrong if a product is bad you can try it
and it's bad in politics it's kind of
hired what's the how do we figure out
what the right answer is what the wrong
answer is because they'll always be a
hundred explanations as to why it failed
even if you do it and and you think that
it's good so you know that's a very long
and rambling way of saying my biggest
fear is that politics ends up dominating
economic growth and trade and
technological advances I think it might
and you might but I am generally an
optimist if you're an old person
watching this online taking up space to
fake news just turn the shirt off
nice positive yeah yeah I thought so
excellent so pro drugs anti LP if you
combine the two you can combine drugs
and all people kill off the old people
yeah yeah alright I feel it was taken in
the wrong direction show some the last
question we always like to ask our guest
is what is the one thing that we're not
talking about that we should be talking
about animal welfare hmm animal welfare
is the thing that we should be talking
about I think that this will be the
thing that has the technological
solution and I think that as we are
increasingly able to grow meat not mean
not read replicas but actual meat in
factories and in labs think that we will
begin to realize that the way animals
are treated in our in our world is is
very very bad and I suspect it's the
thing that our children will look to us
and say why on earth why the hell were
you treating animals that way Wow
there we go you're vegan no his meat
tastes good yeah yeah I do I do eat and
humanely reared meat
my view is that it's bait it's better to
have lived a life that's good and then
to be killed than to have never lived at
all I would much rather if my own life
if you said to me you can either never
be born or you'll live your life and
then at the age of 40 somebody's going
to kill you and eat you I would
definitely take the second one and I
think the most animals would probably
made that choice too if they could so I
think that veganism isn't actually
demanded but he eating humanely treated
animals is can you write that down for
me so I can regurgitate it then next
time someone lectures me yeah you had
Diana Fleischman on earth yes and I had
this debate with her occasionally she
completely thinks I'm wrong and she's a
lot smarter than me so all right well
that we've had you on as well thank you
so much for coming on you're on Twitter
at s 8 MB the number 8 like Sam B but
with the number 8 and these are anything
else that you would like to promote as
we know anything in particular you know
write in the book yet you know no I
don't the attention span to write a book
well when you do which I suspect you
probably will
let us know well thanks very much again
really enjoyable coming here yeah really
nice conversation I thought yeah great
stuff thank you thank you I'm at
Constantin kissing you can follow me
into it as well I'm a failing human and
if you've enjoyed the podcast please
give us a rating on iTunes
five stars thank you comment thank you
and tell a friend you can also go on
YouTube it give us a follow stop us in
and there was something to do with a
bell who supposes that there's a bell
next to subscribe button if you click
that you will actually get notifications
when we put a video there you go
Francis's as an old person he's not
familiar with technology I know I love
fight news alright thank you very much
and we'll see you next week